please ensure that microphones are muted
when you are not speaking
that you do not interrupt other speakers
members are reminded not to use
messaging
chat functions during the meeting unless
it is reported
a peculiar non-pecunial interest or
notify the chair that you wish to make a
proposal
that if you are attending a meeting to
speak
or sorry to speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask
questions by the chair please await your
turn
if members lose connection to the
meeting
that they must contact the member
support officer
mandy smith as soon as possible you
should all have the number
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcasted
live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeating viewing it's back on again
are you all right sorry keep cutting
sean i'm cutting in and out
welcome sean the whole of the meeting
will be recorded except where there are
confidential or accent items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be
deemed by the council to have consented
of being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you're also
consistent to being recorded by the
council
and sorry consented to being recorded by
the council
and to the possibility of those sounds
recorded being
webcast and or training purposes
and there's more the council members of
the public
and the press may record film or for
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public
and the press are not lawfully excluded
right thank you for that now uh move to
the agenda
uh apologies for absence and
substitutions
the covenants officer karen will do
a uh roll call
thank you chair members if you could
reply with good morning or present when
i call out your name please
councillor suez good morning
councillor peter beer
councillor beer your mike's off peter
it it keeps disappearing the bar at the
bottom but anyway
um bear with me uh i'll leave that on
yes i'm present
thank you councillor carpendale present
counselor trevor creswell
i don't think he's here councillor sean
dawson
president councillor mcfrazer
president councillor jane gould good
morning
councillor margaret mabry good morning
councillor mark newman yeah councillor
john nan
present thank you chair thank you all
because that's a good turnout
right um now for decorations of interest
by the councillors have we got any
no no no no
right um to come i item 3
blr194 to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 14th
of february 2020 are there any points
regarding the accuracy of the meeting
all right could i have a proposal i
propose
i propose they are accepted
so uh second please yes
my second sue carpenter thank you the
government's officer will now take a
roll call
thank you chair members if you could
reply with four against or abstain
councillor suez or
councillor peter beer four
councillor stu carpendale four
councillor sean dawson
councillor
i dawson she's having trouble with her
counselor dawson are you there
yes paul thank you councillor mcfrazer
ab councillor jane gould
or councillor margaret mabry
for councillor mark newman for
councillor john nunn war thank you chair
that's carried
okay johnny good the minutes of the
meeting have been confirmed and will be
signed at the next practical opportunity
uh now to receive notification of
petitions
with the council's petition scheme mr
chairman before that
could could i ask a question about um
a process that was due to be done with
the minutes
yes go on yeah it's margaret mabry
um at on the second page
uh 6.5
there was going to be a letter sent to
suffolk county council highways
outlining concerns about um regular and
disabled parking spaces within the town
of sudbury
specifically on the market hill area
could
someone confirm that that was done
please and whether we had a reply
now can anyone an officer reply to that
one
david do you know anything about this
no chair i can't actually answer that
one
if i can just help uh i remember
councillor maybe um proposing that and i
think i
uh seconded it because uh we were
concerned um
about that and as far as i'm aware i
don't think
it's arrived at county i haven't seen or
heard anything
okay well can i ask them carolyn could
you look into that and
let the committee know a later date i
don't want to go into a conversation
about that at the moment
yes of course officers can look into
that okay and uh send us all that the
committee an email out with
what's happened on that one thank you
all right thank you thank you margaret
right so
um right to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's
petition scheme have we received any
there none received chair
questions from councillors none received
chair
okay all right now we move on to
item six blr 19 stroke five
table affairs for hackney carriages i
will now
invite the licensing officer to
introduce the report
to the committee that's david
thank you chair hey david this report is
to consider responses received during
the public consultation exercise
against the revised table of fares for
fix for hackney carriages operating in
the cro
controlled zone or the baby district
which should i sing a regulatory
committee you approve for public
consultation at the meeting of the 14th
of february 2020
there are two options for members to
consider
and these are listed at 2.1 officers
have undertaken the statutory
consultation exercise as
instructed by the committee at the
meeting of the 14th of february 2020.
the committee in accordance with the
1976 act
has two options to consider having had
due regard to the objections received
which has not been withdrawn
objections which have been received are
attached to this report as appendix c
and officers comments to those
objections are attached as appendix d
option one that no change is necessary
to revise table
affairs fix for hackney carriages
operating a controlled zone of the baby
district
option two that members are minded
to modify the revised table affairs
fixed for hackney carriages operating
the control tone of the baby district
to assist the committee in its
deliberations officers have
reviewed the objections received and
they were created an
alternative tariffs for committee's
consideration
these are attached to this report as
appendix e
recommendations let the committee
consider the two
options set out in in 2.1 above
and there are recommendations to cabinet
at 3.2
the recommendation the cabinet is the
committee is asked following
consideration options one and two above
to make recommendations to cabinet on a
revised table of fares attached as
appendix a
in the following way that the revised
table affairs be adopted whether the
committee is minded to modify the table
or not
and in accordance with section 65 of the
local government's
lanes provisions act of 1976 recommend a
new date
which is to be set for the third table
affairs to become effective
no later than two months after the
specified date of the 1st
june 2020
local authorities have the power to fix
maximum rates of fares for hackney
carriages within
their district by virtue of section 65
of the 76 act
there are no statute powers to set fares
for private hire vehicles
a hackney cash may apply for hire and
wait on the rank
private hire vehicles must be pre-booked
and operators may set their own charges
affairs for hackney carriages within the
baba district have not increased
since august 2016 and a review of
revision
and consultation held now been
undertaken
it will be an operational decision for
each operator proprietor where the
maximums are charged
as they are as their discretion to
charge less
than than they wish and a passenger
is entitled to attempt to negotiate a
lesser fare
however proprietors must meter the
maximum fares permissible
in the district maximum fares should be
transparent to the fair paying passenger
and should enable officers to charge
realistic fares
the consultation the consultation public
notice was issued to
the loca in the local press a notice was
posted
the council offices and notices were
placed at the
customer access points in the district
to advertise the proposed variation
to the hackney carriage table affairs as
required
by section 65 of the local government
lanes prisons act 1976
responses were received from the hackney
carriage trade objecting to the table
affairs for hackney carriages
and are attached to the report as
appendix c there have been no responses
to the table affairs from the general
public during the consultation period
and that includes the officer's report
okay thank you david is there
members is there any items of
clarification
i'll go down soon as
no thank you peter beer
yes could i just be clarified because
there's a lot of paperwork on this
um the the uh you said it was 2.1 and
3.2
um in the report and recommendation one
and two can you just remind me
what what sort of increase that is
because there's such a lot of um figures
given in all this
thank you i appreciate that counselor
option obviously it's 2.1
option one is obviously there's no
change and you keep the table affairs
that you went out to consultation with
option two and it's going to
appendix e which
is on so i'll get there a minute
this is on page 47 and there are
examples there for you to consider so
you've also got an example to increase
the initial flag fare
and exam there's then four examples
of tariffs that you can have a look at
and consider
if you wish to modify the table affairs
thank you okay uh
sue carbondale uh no thank you
sean dalton dawson um yes it's one of
the things i wanted
i understood that um the government
guidelines might be slightly amended due
to the kovid 19 and that some of the
affairs might be adjusted
um and i'm just wondering whether um you
know quite happily
support this at the moment but whether
is there room if that happens for this
to be amended at a later date to reflect
those changes
and that's that question no this this is
the only chance to modify the table of
fares we'd have to go out for public
consultation if the table needed to be
done again at a later date
so how would that work then with some of
the government's
advice saying that they my understanding
is that they're thinking
of making some changes
what what it is acne carriages are set
at a maximum rate of fair and it's
down to the driver themselves yes at
their discretion whether they charge
less than the maximum rate of fare so if
government is
suggesting and i would hasten to guess
that they would ever regulate
acne charities because it's a local
issue um
it's it's it's a hard one um to
determine that that this this is
obviously a maximum table of affairs i
i couldn't second guess what the
government are going to come out with
all right thank you perhaps could i just
um
cut in here slide just to give a little
bit of advice from the legal perspective
i'm not aware of any legislation that
the government is proposing
but it does have the power to propose to
um
for both primary legislation which
override
the regulations that control the the
taxi fares so it is possible that
um the government may impose something
probably on a temporary basis if they do
that's what i it's a later understand
and that's why i was just asking for
clarification
that that is a possible but it is you
know we have very little knowledge of it
and how that would work at the moment
okay thank you
thank you sean thank you nigel all right
mike fraser
no comments jane gold
yeah my comments would have been around
the kobe situation and um
whether there's any mitigation in place
for any changes it might
it might bring into effect but i think
you've answered it thank you
oh jolly good margaret mayberry
thank you mr chairman and my apologies
for the work phone going off that should
never have
been working today but there we go
something always happens doesn't it
um i do have one question
i don't know whether it's valid here or
not but i will ask it
um is there a charge for the taxis to
actually wait in the rank
please
no there's no charge for them to wait in
the rank they're there
obviously waiting in the rank waiting
for their fam when it's when
the passenger gets in the vehicle that
the meter is activated
so if i may to come back on that so the
actual
taxi rank um the demarcation lines and
the tarmac etc is paid for by um
suffolk county uh well i suppose it
would be the town
council it's paid for out of
uh hacking carriage fees rather than
fares
i don't understand sorry uh we pay
for as part of
um carrie's fee is for
um looking after hackney carriage
ranks it's part of the fee rather than
the fair
okay that um that helps enormously thank
you
so we paid for that really right uh john
now
no comment okay thank you all very much
now we'll now open this item up for
debate
i will now go down the names again soon
as
nothing to say at the moment thing all
right peter beer
yes please mr chairman um yes i'm i'm a
little bit
concerned and confused i think with
these charges
and i've looked at them two or three
times uh
i'm sure we all had an email
we were all copied in from one of the
taxi
people i'm not sure if it was double a
or treble a but anyway
they were quite unhappy with these
charges being proposed
and yet when you read through the
paperwork it looked like they were
getting an increase
but according to the um
a person who wrote the letter to us all
uh this wasn't the case
where is the discrepancy what's wrong
because i i'm just not happy about this
at the moment
right just david have you got anything
on this have you
have you seen the letters
yes yeah i've seen i've seen the email
traffic uh
an answer to the councillor's question
um
it stems from percentages within table
affairs
table percentages can be read one of two
ways
or several different ways um so
percentages in in tariffs it's really a
no-no
which is why that we've come forward
with a clear and concise table
uh back in february we've now listened
to
responses from the trade and this is why
you've now got an appendix e
with some example alternatives for your
consideration
can i come back mr chairman of course
yeah um
right so you're saying that we consulted
with other organizations or taxi drivers
and the majority of them have come back
and they support
this um the proposals that you're
putting forward
because when i read this email
um i have to admit i came down on the
side of the
um email people that that theirs seem
much more
sensible workable and more
understandable than our one
can you help because uh you know it's no
good saying
um you've heard back from who we really
need to know this is all the
the taxi drivers or how many of them uh
were supported of this
or is this one just a lone voice
an answer to the counsellor's question
obviously the consultation responses are
in appendix c
they're the ones that have responded to
the consultation process
following that consultation process
officers have looked at those
responses that are in c and giving some
different work working examples in
appendix
e so there's a there's an
increase on a running mode in
in examples
two three and four uh there's a
difference in waiting time
in examples three and four there's an
increase to what they
that what is perceived to be getting
that's why percentages within tariffs
can be read so many different ways i can
be looking at one way
you could be looking at some other
direction the public could be looking at
a different way
and the licensed trade is looking at it
somewhere else that's why percentages
and tariffs are
really something that shouldn't be there
and that's why we came forward with a
clear and concise table affairs so it
could be read by all it could be read by
the media manufacturer it could be read
by ourselves
as officers and yourselves as
councillors
and the general public and the trade and
we're all singing on the
same hem sheet rather than everybody
saying different things
okay peter well no this confused me even
more
thank you mr chair all right okay so
calm down
thank you just uh a few comments perhaps
before we
we really open up the debate here um
i i see that we really want to try to
simplify
uh the fares and the tariffs
as they increase and so on in different
different tariff rates
and to be as transparent as we can be
for both the customer and the operator
i think what we're all concerned about
is that we ensure that
drivers and operators don't lose out and
that they do
have an improvement in their income from
the 2016 levels
uh obviously a lot of attention has been
paid to the input from the consultees
and we should thank them for the uh the
time and trouble they've gone to
uh i i think i'm i'm happy with going
away with the percentages
in favor of what are very clearly
stipulated tariffs
um and obviously we want the best
options for drivers and operators
maybe as we sort of consider further
appendix e we could look at what are the
best options for the drivers and
operators at that point
so i think i'll wait to see what what
other folk have to say at this stage
thank you
thank you sir uh sean dawson
sean yeah i'm fine thank you
mike fraser
yeah yes mark thank you um i mean we
spoke yesterday on this and really just
to
uh reiterate uh what peter was saying
it's just been a mass
of um figures um it's a lot of it
confuse each other
so i'm i'm looking what i understand
that
this is certainly has a 12-month period
uh trial period so that they it will be
reviewed
annually so if the figures don't work in
practice
then it can be reviewed and adjusted as
necessary and it's
after 12 months okay thank you mike
uh jane gold yeah we've had emails
haven't we from fox cars
and from stuart armstrong of triple a
cabs
and neither of these gentlemen seem to
be particularly happy with what's being
proposed
but again i think probably what people
have said i would agree with that
it does need to be simplified as far as
we can and still be a working
proposition
um and if it has to be that complicated
as the figures
the different terrorists are showing us
at the moment well so be it
but i am a bit concerned that these two
gentlemen and they have sent into the
they've responded to the consultation
haven't they haven't just sent emails
and that the two these two gentlemen
don't seem to be particularly happy with
it
i think that's all i've got to say
really at this moment thank you john
margaret mayberry thank you mr chairman
um we we seem to have had a
a raft of responses from the operators
which is
which is concerning um
not to confuse matters but to ask the
quest
another question which is um
have we actually undertaken um
an exercise that actually includes
the taxi overhead such as insurance
which i know is high
um and average running costs of the
vehicle and i know that
alters depending on what vehicle it is
to see whether
um they are just they are stating
a fact that we need to take into
consideration
or whether we we haven't done it um
i was really surprised to see that the
um each subsequent 110 yards would
be 10p which is exactly the same as they
had in 2016
and that concerns me thank you
all right thank you margaret uh
john ran no questions at this time
all right okay i'll just comment
i think we are um
trying to streamline it a bit and i
think
david probably can uh back me up on this
i think some items have dropped
and some items have gone up but are they
better off at the end of august
david please
which table are you talking about the
table affairs under appendix
i'm just saying generally i like that
the taxi driver is going to be better
off that's what i really
if we're looking at appendix a possibly
not
if we're looking at appendix d e so
we can make it better if we modify it
right okay well i'll go back does anyone
else
more want to come back in the debate yes
mr chairman
margaret who's that sorry yes it is uh
it is
margaret maygree um yes uh david didn't
actually answer my
question as to whether we had undertaken
an exercise about insurance
um and vehicle running costs etc if he
could please
yeah david please
yes chair and i confirm yes we do
thank you okay have we got any more
questions from anyone
uh yes please play the bear
thank you mr chairman um yes uh
um you're saying that we're going to
review this or suppose we review this in
12 months time
and i believe you said the start date
would be two months after june or
something so is that the first of august
that's one question
um which means we'd review it august
next year
um but i i i would still like to know
whether they are going to be
better off with these figures because
every way i looked at it didn't seem as
though they were going to be better off
and i'm still not convinced of that mr
chairman i'm sorry
okay david would you like to come back
apparently
they will be better off depending on
which example you're looking at
okay well well which example have i got
a look at to have it better off
because um is that going to be the same
example
that they'll be working on so they'll be
better off
or or do they choose another example and
they're worse off
you see it's so confusing i appreciate
that counselor
example if you look at example three and
four for example
they have a better running running mile
and a better waiting time
if we were looking at example four for
example they would have a better
running mile and an even greater waiting
time
thank you but it hasn't helped me i'm
sorry i know
it is very confusing that's the that is
the trouble but
we are trying to simplify it that's the
main thing we're trying to do
i mean if i jump in a taxi and i want to
go from
and i'll have to use my examples locally
from sudbury to hadley
i would want to know x amount of pounds
it was going to cost me
and uh let's say the figure that he
charges
today is uh so much
and on the first of august when these
increases come in if that's the date and
you haven't confirmed that yet
um would that be more
chair would it help members if they
looked at appendix f
and specifically page two there's some
example journeys there for example
typical example journeys one from east
street taxi rank
to tesco's and sudbury one from
aldi in suburu to beerus
one from morrisons and hadley to culture
to hospital
and one from rudbridge corner to
stansted airport
does everyone got there
mr chairman margaret mabry i know um
sue carpenter councillor carvedale's
trying to speak
uh could i speak after her please thank
you
yeah sue come in
we all have the same quandary at the
moment um we want to ensure
that the operators and drivers are going
to be better off than they are at
present
um if the the indication from the
officer
appears to be that the the more
advantageous
examples on appendix e
uh would be three and four uh would that
be correct
david um and if so are those the
the two that perhaps we should be
debating in in order to put forward a
proposal at some point
without leading members yes examples
three and four will
give the taxi drivers more more in terms
of waiting
waiting time in example four along with
the
an increase to their running mile on all
tariffs
an example three will give a greater
running mile than they're getting now
which is exactly the same running mark
as example four
and they will get the waiting time
they're perceivedly getting
in the current table affairs
okay is that all right sir um yes
i i think if that helps members
generally
we could perhaps hone in on those two
particular examples and then
maybe david could talk us through how
they relate to appendix f
because i think um you know it's evident
there's a massive amount of work been
done underneath all of this
uh but it is very confusing um for us
just looking at all the figures
so we okay uh margaret do you want to
come in now quickly
before we yes thank you thank you mr
chairman margaret mabry
um i concur with what people are saying
it
is very it is very confusing and being
a person who likes figures um well it's
been fun
um i'm beginning to
have the opinion that i don't really
know
enough about this um and
i'm going to suggest that perhaps we
should have had
between when the consultation went out
and coming
back today that we should have had some
more training
in between so we could all every single
one of us have
a firmer idea of of this
um i appreciate there's been a lot of
work going through and when i have
spoken to
um an officer i have had
very good information back and it's been
very precise and
very quick so thank you for that however
i am not
an expert on this and i do not really
wish to be seen to be making
a taxi driver um worse off particularly
in this current climate thank you okay
thank you margaret
anyone else want to come in yes please
mr chair um
jane gould here uh again i've got the
email from sean fox from
fox cars um and i know everyone's busy
and everyone's being
been sort of a bit covered um even
busier
but i am concerned about the email that
says that he tried to speak to you david
tried to contact you on several
occasions even leaving messages asking
you to contact him but he had no replies
my concern is that um this gentleman who
is a taxi driver has come up with his
own proposals
i just want assurance really that he has
been heard and that his
proposals have been considered and i
would just ask the question why he's
feeling that he hasn't been heard
and he's feeling that he hasn't been
contacted
all right thank you jane david would you
like to come back with this uh chair i'm
unaware of any contact from from fox
cars to myself
it's not something that i'm aware of and
something i will look into
uh an answer to the council's question
on fox cars
fox cars within their consultation
response
um we're looking for a running mile of
one pound seventy
um we in exact examples
uh two three and four have
increased the running mile on tariff one
to one pound
eighty which is more than the one pound
sixty that they are getting currently
so they're getting more that's what we
want to hear isn't it
so that's what do we have to vote on
three or four or both
that david
you if you're reminded to modify the
table under option two
it's what exa if you were thinking of a
different example
uh under appendix e it's which example
you prefer
to modify the three tariffs
so yeah i would take a vote on those
three tariffs
that's two options which is three and
four which is we believe is better for
the taxi driver yes
yes yeah it is better for the taxi
driver all right
come back to the committee any other
comments on that
mr chairman i did put a question mark in
the box i don't know if
you're getting at your end yeah peter
thank you um could i just ask
um david whether he could confirm the
date that it would start
uh was one and secondly um jane
very kindly uh counselor gold very
kindly pointed out
um in the email um
that uh the figures why are the figures
that the operator gave not acceptable
and perhaps haven't been followed
through
because you you haven't given really any
comment on that
this is an operator who who's in the
business
who's given an idea the sort of charges
that that
should be expected now he may be way
over the top i don't know
but you must have uh analyzed those
figures that he sent you in
in that email can you please answer that
thank you
and the date david yes chair
the date is for you to determine
in your recommendation to cabinet so i
suggest you we park
that one till you've made a
determination whether you're modifying
the table affairs or not
um on the second point yes officers have
heard what drivers have said which is
why we've worked up
some different examples and they're
attached as appendix e
they're over and above what they're
perceivingly getting
now which is what
i'm trying to get members to have a look
at
peter do you want to come back uh
i i i still am at a loss i'm sorry
um i'll have to just listen to more of
the debate thank you
anyone else wants to speak yes please mr
chairs it's
jane gould again here and there's a
similar email from stuart armstrong from
aaa cabs and with some counter proposals
that i
would just like an assurance that his
counter proposals have been looked at in
detail as well
and perhaps the thinking behind why we
why officers feel they wouldn't work
david
very good which part of the council
prefers or the one he sent him first off
that is the original consultation
response the second email or the third
email
i've got in front of me an email sent on
the 10th of june which is only two days
ago from stuart armstrong
please find attached accountable person
for the new hackney race
discussion splits the travis into six
block arrival
i don't need to read it all out um so
very recent i looked at that yes
yesterday obviously i've
the worked up proposals were worked up
on the
examples given in the consultation
responses under appendix c
i'm not saying his proposals won't work
however i
i have worked on on those proposals to
have a look to see whether they will or
won't work
sorry you you've looked at stuart
armstrong from aaa cabs proposals have
you to see whether they
won't work yes i have looked at them if
you want me to go over that i'm willing
to do so
what do other counsellors think uh
can i speak yes sir i feel
looking at that email that came in two
days ago i think it came in too late for
us to give due consideration to it
um i appreciate that again um there was
a lot of contribution there
but i i personally would prefer not to
not to go looking into that with
with inadequate notice inadequate
opportunity really to consider what's
being said
and it departs from the paper that we
have in front of us
from the officers i'd be more than happy
to
hold that over for perhaps when we look
at uh the review
again annually we're going to be
proposing that when the policy is
reviewed that there is an annual
uh review of all affairs and so on um
i'm not happy at considering that
document at all at this stage
okay can i
comment yes um so
um you're very knowledgeable and what
have you no disrespect to you
i i think most likely what you're saying
i can understand but
i do feel that when somebody has written
something in like this
and because it may have got to us too
late
um he did send to others previous um
it seems a bit hard that we're not
considering that somehow shape or form
i do have strong reservations on this so
at the moment
i'm not convinced that the the way
forward is to accept the officer's
recommendation at this stage
um i'm sorry i haven't been convinced
yet
um but with no disrespect to councillor
carpenter
so david did look at has looked at the
emails
and um they've come up with a proposal
can i come back on can i come back
example four
will give what um
the email has in some respects on tariff
one two and three
especially on waiting time especially on
running mile even in tariff one is one
pound eighty
from our example four to his example in
tariff one is one pound sixty which is
what they're getting now
so if you look at example four which is
a one pound eighty running mile compared
to one pound sixty
which option would you prefer the one
that i'm suggesting an
example for or his example at one pound
sixty
right okay
all right like margaret maybe do you
want to speak again
yes thank you thank you mr mr chairman
um
i i do concur with um councillor beer
here
um i would have preferred um some more
training um on this to give a
what i would call a content decision
for myself on this okay
thank you and anyone else would like to
speak
if not i'm gonna dip my toe in the water
so
on the proposal for three and four um do
i have a proposal
i'll replace it who's that sorry sean
dawson i'll prepares it
thank you sean john proposer and a
second
second are we proposing here three
and all four three and four is that
okay david can i do that i think we need
one or the other
it's one or the other chair it's either
three or four preferably
well four's better for the taxi drivers
so that's what i think
we'll go for for sean do you want to
come back and just propose that again
yes sorry
for clarity i'll propose four i would
second
and so we'll second that okay um
i think we do do we need to go to a
debate or do we go to the vote
karen so are you clear on the proposal
yeah everybody clear we um um david at
this point do we need to um set the date
or should we do that separately
do that separately karen okay so this is
the proposal for
example four on appendix e
yeah okay members if you could reply
with four against or obscene please
counselor airs four councillor beer
against councillor carpendale four
councillor dawson four councillor fraser
four councillor gould abbey stone
councillor mayberry abstain
councillor newman four councillor nunn
abstain okay
okay that's um five four
three abstains and one against so it's
carried
that's carried and that goes through to
the cabinet
to look at that's a recommendation to
cabinet so now we need a proposal on the
start date
shall i help for clarity yeah
okay so for clarity you you need to set
a date between
the 7th of july and the 1st of august
and what do you recommend i recommend
that you look at
say for example 12th of august
no you can't do that peter
look at the week of the 27th of july
all right 27th of july all right do we
have a proposal for that
proposed carpenter i'll second it
i need an exact same chair 27
27. you is it
monday the 27th of july
is that okay
thank you chair all right come here
sorry can i have a proposal again
i'll propose it no who just proposed it
first
see i think i did yes all right so and
then uh mike can uh second that is that
okay
that's fine right okay can i ask the
question on that
yes go on pia um mr chairman
um does that mean that we would review
this
then in one year's time which would be
the 27th of
july 21 is that correct david
we may look to uh review it before then
but yeah we will review each table
affairs annually
so we'll review this each year and then
we can see how this year goes and then
we can have a look at it again
next year but hopefully it will go
through okay
i'm sorry mr chairman that didn't really
answer my question
because we need a date to say that it
could be earlier
it may not be so may it be the 27th
of um july 21 we can't give it to
another date
date peter because we've got a look at
when it's available to have the meeting
haven't we
well you're asking us to vote on
on uh proposing this to start
and then it will be reviewed 12 months
later
yeah but mr david said that it may not
be
it could be earlier so again it's not
clear
i'm sorry mr mr chairman um
i concur with peter again we need a date
that says specifically
uh that this will be reviewed on i'm
going to say
the day before which is the 26th of july
or before if needed so we need a date
when it will
exactly be looked at um
this this is it this is a precise date
okay margaret thank you david can we do
that
chair this is not part of that that
recommendation the recommendation is to
set a
date for to go to cabinet
for these table affairs to become
effective all right so
if you think if jeff you're thinking of
doing a
separate recommendation to officers that
you
wish us to review the table affairs in a
year's time
that would be my suggestion okay
could something also be referred to the
um
the deliberations when the policy itself
is reviewed
so that it stipulates that you know two
months before
whatever the the review is is carried
out with consultation
so yeah so we've got a policy meeting
where we're going to say we want to
review and then
at that meeting we could pick the date
is that does that sound safe is that
that's like you should come forward
october
november-ish isn't it yeah
so should we we'll do the date when we
have to review
the meeting about the reviews that sound
better is there doing it all today
i don't think that would be lost
entirely now well peter we've got a
meeting in a couple of months time where
we're going to say that we're changing
the policy so that we can review this
every year
so when we change the policy we can say
that we review it every year and then we
can put the review date in
thank you mr chairman um i don't think
that we knew that there would be a
review date in october that's why we are
confused
but if you are confirming that we are in
october
having a licensing and regulatory
committee
meeting in october that will review this
and possibly other policies
then i'm i am content with that thank
you
okay can you clarify that is that
correct
um is that correct david is that when
we're expecting the
item to come back to committee emma
might be able to help
that's when we're looking to have the
policy brought
forward to two members the full policy
on hackney carriage and
higher vehicles yeah perhaps i can help
a little bit there
um alongside this piece of work we've
already started reviewing the actual
baby mid suffolk policies on taxis and
private hire and that's due to come
before committee in october so that
would seem to be
an appropriate time then to set a date
for an annual review
okay i'm happy with that is everyone
else happy with that
yes okay thank you very much well that's
that part of the meeting finished now
we're going to move on to item seven
sorry check can we just take a vote on
the proposed date
for the um oh yeah twenty prepare to
become effective
yeah okay do i do the roll call on that
thank you if you could just answer four
against abstain again
council of heirs for
councillor beer against councillor
carpendale
four councillor dawson four
councillor fraser four councillor gold
four councillor mabry
sorry councillor mayberry i'm okay
pardon
um abstain i didn't vote for the policy
so i'm going to at stay
counselor newman and councillor nan
abstain thank you that's carried
okay thank you all very much but we now
move to uh
item seven paper blr stroke 19
6 provision of taxi
parks in sudbury i'll ask the licensing
officer coming with a report
david
thank you chair this report is to
appoint a new hackney carriage stand
commonly known and otherwise in this
report referred to as
taxi ranks as required by section 63 of
the local government
misplaced provisions act of 1976
following the public consultation
exercise which the licensing and
regulatory committee approved at the
meeting of the 14th
of february 2020 all options to be
considered are contained in the
recommendations below
the recommendations for councillors
today are
that the committee approved the
appointment of a new hackney carriage
stand
on king street in sudbury
that the committee authorized officers
to make an order appointing the hackney
carriage
stand on king street as detailed in
appendix a
to this report whether this
within the district there are currently
three areas in sudbury
where a point appointed
taxi ranks are located these are on east
street
open old marketplace and at the railway
station
as within most districts or borough
areas there are simply not enough
towns center space available to provide
attack
a rank space for each licensed acne
carriage
however this is mitigated by the ability
for hackney carriages to form their own
ranks
apply for hire wait for business or be
pre-booked anywhere
in the controlled zone for which they
are licensed
this is subject to relevant traffic
controls
mobile technology has also increased
diversity for hackney cash proprietors
who may be contacted direct direct
provide
hands-free bluetooth driving to
immediately collect a customer from a
given location
all licensed hackney county providers
are encouraged to
operate sensibly and flexibly to ensure
that town center traffic
flow is not compromised by excessive
queuing
or unlawful parking waiting of hackney
carriages to access
full ranks
business diversification is also
encouraged so that greater
links may be established in areas of
the district beyond subaru town centre
licensed taxis and private hire vehicles
provide a valuable contribution to the
safer
vibrant nighttime economy local business
school transport an event tourist
attraction supporting within the
district
the power for district councils to
appoint hackney carriage stand
is contained within section 631 of the
local government miscellaneous
provisions act
1976 this legislation enables district
councils
for the purpose to appoint taxi ranks in
any highway in
district that is maintainable at the
public expense
we consent of the highway authority and
with consent of
the landowner or any land in the
district
which does not form part of the highway
so maintainable
it also empowers such councils from time
to time to vary the number of
taxes permitted at each rank
before creating any sex rank or varying
the numbers of taxes allowed there
the district council must give notice to
chief officer police for the area
shall also give notice of the pros over
the advertisement
in at least one local newspaper
circulation district and consider any
responses
received as a result of the public
consultation
this this consultation process
must allow for a minimum 28 days for
people to respond
consultations
suffolk county council highway section
has already been
has already consulted the licensing team
on changes being made to sudbury and
they're creating a
traffic regulation order is pending the
outcome of this committee
suffolk constabulary as a statutory
consultant has been consulted on the
creation of a taxi rank on king street
sudbury
and have made no comments against the
proposed rank
the po the strategy public notice was
issued in the local press
on the 5th of march 2020 a notice was
posted that the
council offices and also noticed were
placed at the customer access points
within the district
to advertise the proposed hackney
carriage rank as required by section
3 of the 76 act there have been no
responses
to the rank creation from the general
public or the licensed trade during the
consultation period and that includes
the officer's report
okay thank you david um right we'll go
for
any points of clarification suez
sue no i know fine very very good thank
you
please
yeah just a question uh for
clarification
um the disabled drivers that
are at the moment um parking there
um have they um commented
on um this being taken away
uh for their use
uh that well first of all it's
is it's not a disabled parking space
there it's just uh double
double yellow lines and that they do
park there but david have you got
anything to say on that have we had any
confrontation
from people no as i said in the officers
report there have been no cons
no responses to the consultation
exercise none at all peter
so just following on from that
so obviously we discussed this some time
ago
and we suggested that the disabled could
move around the corner in front of um
boots that sold at the top end um
so what i'm concerned is
one day we're going to go along there
and paint in the taxi rank
and all these disabled drivers are going
to say they know nothing about
it or or are aware
of all this happening or are they
because they are aware that we're going
to create
four i think it said some time ago but i
think it's only going to be three at the
very most
david's any reply to that chair
um our our bit will be just the rank
creation and there will be highways
painting
the rank at the rank highways obviously
your pen the rest of pentax a
is down to suffolk highways and their
responsibility
okay right okay thank you right sue calm
down
uh thank you chair i was also going to
um just
ask for some clarification on the
disabled parking places
um we say that there are now
specifically going to be new parking
places which
were not beforehand is that correct and
there seems to be some debate as to
whether there are going to be three
or four and how does this compare with
where they seem to be parking at the
moment
david yeah i
i will state that we have no control
over over parking that is
suffolk county council's remit and this
is suffolk county council's plan
so the theirs is under the traffic
regulation order ours is only limited to
the acne carriage rank
so just so i know the area there's
normally
three or four cars disabled cars parked
there
right on that spot and then we're gonna
make that into the taxi bit and
hopefully we get three or four parking
spaces outside
um the clark shop right yes i mean
the the fact that they they are now
going to be uh dedicated disabled
parking seems to me to be something of
an improvement
yeah i agree with you on that yeah okay
thank you
sean dawson i'm fine
okay mike fraser no i'm fine thank you
clarification uh jane gold well just to
point us again
to fox cars um letter on it um he's got
some thoughts as well on this agenda
item as well as the tariff one
um which i'm i'm sure we've all read
it's in the same email
and and just to sort of say that he's a
bit disgruntled about the communication
process
i'm not saying there's anything wrong
with the communication process i'm
saying that
here's a member of the public who's a
tax driver of some years who is a bit
disgruntled
whether we just need to sort of address
that in some shape or form
but his letter does go into in in some
detail what he feels
and he's saying the addition of a taxi
bank on king street
i don't know the area but it's welcome
but hardly sufficient
as the average length of a taxi is now
4.9 meters
due to the regulations of new happiness
and the requirement that they are
wheelchair accessible
um certainly goes on to to be talking
what you were just saying sue about the
sort of the
um disabled um conditions there really
your new rank is long enough for just
two vehicles but i'm
sure i'm reading this this letter that
you've all read anyway um
i've just got a few concerns about this
letter that he sent really
okay all right again i know yeah i think
they'll get three or four there and
what actually happens where the taxis
park sort of at the end of north street
and then as the road goes up in front of
the the town hall
the taxi drivers actually go over the
other side and park a couple of cars
there and that just causes a bit of
disruption
so by moving that um
that that area which disabled people do
park but it's not a designated disabled
parking and making it a taxi rank
you'll get i would say you'll get three
or four there
and it'll stop the congestion around the
bend because i imagine we'll put
no parking on that bend which we can
look at okay
um and and uh mr fox's letter was uh
uh it was replied uh susan broome
responded to him
i would just like an assurance that she
says
i will review the proposed taxi rank on
king street
in regards to potentially increasing its
length however i should emphasize that
changes will only be possible if they're
supported by the police
and town council amongst others and do
not compromise the voter safety
improvements that we hope to achieve
just just reassurance that she has done
that that she has reviewed this
or or will be doing in the future okay
cameron can we can make sure that
happens
i'm sorry could you repeat that for me
could you repeat that please yes um
this is it's all on the same email that
um
fox cars sent and it was sent on the 6th
of june
and this is it's a letter that was a
reply to mr fox's concerns from a lady
called susan broome
who's the engineer saying that she will
review the proposed taxi rank on king
street
in regards to potentially increasing its
length
um my i'd like an assurance that that
has been done really
so can you just check that's been done
karen she's from clear services
highways right okay i mean i haven't got
that information so
if somebody could forward that to us
that would be that would be good thank
you
i haven't had those emails or okay
make sure you get them thank you okay
right margaret maybe
um thank you mr chairman i did put in
the in the chat box basically what i
wanted to say and because we have not
had a reply
um or we don't know
whether um the letter went to suffolk
county council highways
um as from the minutes in 6.5 of 0.19
um i think this is a bit premature
we we should have had all our ducks in a
line basically
um and had that reply from suffolk
county council before we do this
um yes king street is not a designated
disabled area
however they
they're they have always parked there
because of the ease to get to the
immediate shops that they are asking for
if you actually look on the plan the
area for taxes is 17 meters and the
piece we're giving for disabled is only
13.5
point of order mr chairman is this a
question or are we in debate
is this for clarification we want to
come back and debate
well um well this is this is for
clarification
um basically that
that why was why was not
the letter or the um
yes the letter sent to suffolk county
councils um
before this was this was brought back to
us
right david can you say report apply to
that one
uh i can only reply on the basis that
our consideration is limited to the rank
space
and the rank space only i could take the
councillor's point on disabled parking
but that is something for suffolk
highways to deal with
and it's their consideration and they
have made provision within
their own traffic regulation order not
just on the market hill but also along
jail lane okay i've got to say that that
area where
we're going to put the taxes is not a
designated area for disabled people it's
just where they park with their badges
they park out they park
and i depart with the lights
sorry margaret
and i did and i did say that mr chairman
lovely thank you all right john now
no no comment at the moment right now
we're moved to debate
um so i think sue's got comments who is
yes i have at the moment due to um the
rearrangements we've done at the town
council
and parking will be difficult outside
clarks
but we have extended parking for
disabled in north street
because we've had to do this so there's
enough space for people to queue safely
if there's any help
okay thank you sir peter beer
uh thank you mr chairman yes i've got a
couple of little fins uh first of all i
want to make it quite
clear that i'm not
against disabled parkin or taxi ranks
and i know we're here to discuss the
taxi rank in king street
which at the moment is being used
by disabled drivers who can display
their badge
and park there i'm
in favour of creating this taxi rank
and in that position uh i'm also
as a a knock on effect of this uh would
support
the disabled park and uh in front of
clark's the boots area up the top there
um and that is suffolk county council's
department to sort that one out uh i
don't think there'd be enough
but anyway uh what i want to say is and
where
i am really unhappy about is that
all these so-called improvements which
um
one or two counselors have actually said
um and employed
actually won't be an improvement for the
general
motorists the general motors will suffer
as a result of this
mr chairman uh they will lose the spaces
that will be created by the
new disabled areas if that happened and
so the knock-on effect of this the taxi
rank yes i'm in favor
but it does mean that by putting the
disabled
where they're being proposed to be and i
think that is an ideal spot
that means we lose parking spaces for
normal motorists we're going to lose a
lot more around town
as i'm sure you're aware and as of
yesterday
i had complaints from people who got
tickets in north street
because they were parking longer than
they should have done by the new
civil parking enforcement team nothing
to do with this i know
but it all stems to the lack of parking
that we have in sudbury
which is a major issue that has to be
looked into um and
we're just helping create this problem
more so but going back to what's in
front of us
which is the uh taxi rank being created
in king's
uh kings hill sudbury street
um that uh i i will support that
um but i'm not happy about the rest of
it
we have to look at all this uh park and
generally
and it's not going to end here mr
chairman thank you
thank you for that pete uh um i do agree
with you that
we do need more parking in sudbury
and um we've we've got a look at that
in a future but that's going to be for
other committees i imagine
and a different day but on this eye and
we're going to improve
the taxi rank which definitely does need
him
and we're still going to give disabled
parking as well which is very very
important but i do note that
we need to try and gain some more
parking spaces in sudbury
and i know your champion uh a
multi-story
perhaps that's we've got go on with that
you know especially there's
been other things not going to happen in
sudbury now that might be able to put
their
time on that but thank you for that so
calm down
[Music]
um i yeah i just feel that there's no
perfect answer to
to any of this in in the down center of
sudbury because it um
it is very cramped um it does suffer
from
from traffic and lack of parking um
having said that
um i'm pleased to see that there is some
specified
disabled parking provision and i support
the taxi rank
okay thank you so uh trevor's not here
sue
dawson sean dawson sorry sean uh yes
have you got any comments on this no not
at all thank you
okay mike fraser no all looks good to me
thank you
all right jane gold
no not as such i mean i have just got i
don't get embroidering this really but
as a green council i have just got to
say that um i think we should be
reducing car risks
and carbon emissions and car usage needs
to be reduced but
i don't want to get into a debate about
that this isn't the time or place
thank you okay thank you margaret maybe
thank you thank you i go back to what i
i was saying i was saying before
um we should have had a reply from
suffolk county council about our
our concerns about um other parking um
for the taxi rank i'm concerned that and
that will still not
be enough with the other
taxi rank that's already there that
shows
it says old market place because there
does seem to be an awful lot
at times margaret i gotta say that there
never be enough there never be enough
disabled parking there'll never be
enough
taxi passes what i was talking about i
was talking about
the best we can and with this in front
of us at least we are giving
three or four more parking spaces for
the taxis and we're still going to have
disabled parking but
noted what you're saying now margaret
anymore would you like to carry say
anything else margaret
um yes probably probably quite quite a
bit
i i just think that we're still going to
have a bother
with with the taxes and that i hope um
our
officers have looked into the fact that
taxes do
need some sort of system if
if if this goes through where they wait
elsewhere if there is not designated
areas for them
so they are not parking where they
currently do
on on on the corners of the streets
where we where we um try and travel
through
which is what peter was saying for the
regular i'm going to say regular
motorists who cannot get through because
um
there are either disabled parking in
in areas because they have nowhere else
to go
or there are taxis also blocking um
an area and i think we should all be
aware of that
okay thank you margaret uh john now
yes i support this proposal okay well um
can i have a proposal please
yes yes i'll be quite happy
to propose the uh new taxi rank
um but i i do want to make it clear to
members
and to the public that this will be at a
cost to the general motorist
okay and that is unacceptable but all
right thank you have you got a second ah
whoever that's mike mike fraser seconded
yeah
was that i did i didn't say a word it
was john
is that john john yeah sorry sorry mike
john nunn
second uh okay um
karen do we need to go to the vote on
this now
yes thank you chair would you like to
conduct your vote yep thank you members
if you could reply with four against or
abstain
councillors four thank you
councillor beer for reluctantly
councillor carpendale four
councillor dawson
councillor dawson
sorry you couldn't hear me yes i can now
thank you so it's going intermittent
again
for all against four thank you
councillor fraser for
councillor gold for councillor mayberry
for councillor newman four
and councillor nan four i'll actually
thank you
yeah thank you very much
well um i will ask karen do you want to
um
uh read out the proposal or is that it's
gone through isn't it
yep that's that's all done thank you
chair so that's the end of the meeting i
think
oh thank you all mr chairman thank you
all for attending that was my first
chair
over our virtual or whatever you call it
well done
[Music]
you